talking about social media have you been
watching what stephen crowder
has been getting up to recently you know
i i'm i've been friends with stephen for
years and uh whenever he texts me i sort
of think like uh
what have you done now what did he do
now what did he do this time what's he
in trouble for
and yes i mean they are gunning for him
i think in a special way
because they can go after him on the
jokes and they can say the jokes were
too far
and because he's so mainstream i think
he may be the most mainstream
conservative that big tech has really
gone after
what do you think we've got to learn
from his situation at the moment
well i i love i mean the man has cajones
of steel
i he he may be a complete lunatic he's
so
he's got such brass culions you know
um i mean we have seen this guy be
waterboarded for a very long time
he is he's done all sorts of crazy
things that
most people would not do and he stood up
to big tech and he and he will not
uh bow down and i think the point that
he and i were discussing this the other
day
you go after alex jones oh well alex
jones he's just a kooky far right guy
turns out he
actually appears to have been right
about everything we learn about the gay
frogs and yeah i mean
but uh you know well alex jones he's a
fringe figure okay you go after him you
go after gavin mcginnis gavin mcinnes
founded the proud boy he's very funny
comedian
uh but no he his jokes they went too far
okay you got to get rid of gavin
mcginnis
now you're going after steven crowd i
mean stephen crowder i think he has the
largest
online following of any conservative
basically certainly in the top three
if you go after and you take him out
they can take out any one of us and i
think that's really what this is about
um and i give them a lot of credit you
know i sometimes think if the
if the big tech oligarchs have not gone
after you at all
it means you're doing something wrong it
means that you know you're
when i think of the really squishy
conservative types you know the ones who
write for the atlantic and the
washington post and
go on msnbc or whatever
i i realize they're actually worse than
the left because the left is being
honestly dishonest right the left is
telling you what it what it believes and
all the
ghastly things it wants to do but these
guys
exist to legitimize
the the leftist the liberal
establishment their their role
is to act as a court jester in the
kingdom of liberalism
and uh so whenever you have an actual
conservative raising actual questions
that might seriously threaten the left
well they can't tolerate that you're not
going to get your cnn invitation
and more likely they're going to try to
boot you off like they're doing to
crowder the interesting thing
with talking about gavin mcguinness and
alex jones
is that although those guys had huge
especially alex right like a
terrifyingly big audience
and he's still holding on to it you know
he's broadcasting every day for
ridiculous numbers of hours even more
than you guys
it it certainly does feel like once
someone is pulled out of the
delivery mechanism of normal social
media the youtubes the twitters so on
and so forth like
milo yiannopoulos where the [ __ ] he
you know like what's milot i saw him
throw a half a million pound ring into
the coast of
hawaii a couple of weeks ago and i was
like milo you've been drinking
like that was but i haven't seen him for
ages i'm oh he's still got he's still
got a youtube account
like wow and he's then he's going
through all of this other sort of stuff
but he would have thought
traditionally if milo had gone through
something as big as that it would have
been
everywhere but you really can ex
communicado
you can take someone out of the public
zeitgeist
very easily with this and even if you
know let's say that
steven's got all of every single one of
his four million or whatever it is how
many subs he's got on youtube huge
amount of subs
let's say all of those are part of his
private sites the mug club thing
that's now siloed that's it yes
shy of a very well incentive
incentivized referral scheme that
your audience and you think okay is this
it now i get to affect these people and
that's it
as everybody knows the way that the
delivery mechanisms on youtube work it's
not just the subscribers that see the
content
even if you don't think about the people
that view it it's 10 or 20x the
impressions
and even just seeing the content or
seeing the tweet even if you don't
decide to engage with it
counts for something in terms of moving
so i think
some political commentators specifically
on the right because i think
those guys tend to try and silo
themselves or create these um fallback
plans
a little bit more as you guys you guys
have it as well right you know just in
case big tech decides to come for you
i i think the the idea is fantastic and
it's obviously the only one that you
have
but i don't really think it's an
acceptable or a successful i don't think
anyone should see being cancelled and
still being able to exist and make a
good living
as a success because you are now taken
out
of the people that already subscribe to
your stuff they know
and mostly agree with the talking points
that you've got anyway yes they need to
be
educated and entertained but it i don't
think that should be classed as a
victory if people get cancelled like
that
this is something so few people
understand the
utility of youtube is not primarily
as a broadcast device it's a fine
broadcast system and you know there are
lots of broadcast systems and that
the utility of youtube is the ability of
discovery
right the fact that new people then are
going to find your stuff
so if you get booted out and let's say
you take your million person audience
with you or
your two million person audience with
you okay two million people
out and who knows how many of those will
remain active that's it that's all
you've got and
it will not grow and it will actually
shrink over time as people die and get
interested in other things and go away
and and uh so yes that's not a victory
at all
and the censorship and and the ostracism
is real i mean milo
yiannopoulos got truly canceled truly
unpersoned
and and now he's out of the public
discourse so
this again ties into the trap
conservatives are reacting to cancel
culture
one of two ways either they'll say you
know alex jones really did say some
things that are not good and that's okay
i think was fine as long as it's just
alex and it's totally fine right so
those the squishes go along with it and
then the other way
is we should never cancel anybody but
there is a third option here which is we
should cancel other people
and i just think that this middle idea
we should never cancel anybody is
has never existed anywhere all societies
have standards
all societies have taboos also when you
transgress those they will
ostracize you and this has been true
in the furthest animals of history all
the way up until the present the
question is
what is the taboo who is going to be
ostracized in the 1940s and 50s
we prosecuted and ostracized many
communists this was colloquially known
as mccarthyism
but it wasn't just mccarthy i mean he
was one anti-communist senator but
there was the house committee on on
american activities there was the
hollywood blacklist
these were largely distinct institutions
and what it meant was if you were
advocating the overthrow of the united
states government the way of life
if you were actively supporting the
communist party which is uh a front for
the soviet union
then you were out you were canceled and
i think that's a great thing
the difference is that in the 1950s you
were cancelled if you were
a communist and today you are cancelled
if you are not a communist
and it's you know if if conservatives
understand this
and we say you know ostracizing people
who are
contrary to our understanding of the
world in our way of life you know
that's a fine thing what the what the
left will tell us and the squishes will
tell us is
well now you're no different than the
left but we are it actually is a
different thing to cancel communists as
it is to cancel
anti-communists and it's a different
thing to wave the the hammer and sickle
than it is to wave
the american flag and i just think that
yes politics involves form it involves
certain you know broad abstractions but
it also involves
substance in particulars what are you
being cancelled
for that's not a very scalable solution
is it
it means that each individual
broad range each region of cancellations
needs to be looked at upon its own
merits that's going to be much more
effortful
that's going to be a challenge well it
requires
some kind of conservative unity so right
now you know
with the with the current cancel culture
which is exclusively leftist
we know the criteria it's if you say
anything
that can in any way be disingenuously
twisted and misinterpreted to to
be racist sexist homophobic
transphobic phobic phobic whatever you
know whatever the list goes on and on
if you in any way contradict the leftist
orthodoxies
you can be canceled
and uh and if they just don't like the
cut of your jib and you say any like i
think of my my daily wire colleague gina
carano
who who tweeted out something that was
anti-nazi
and the left interpret it it completely
flipped it on its head and said it was
pro-nazi or something that therefore you
know you could you could get rid of her
it's just because they didn't like her
because she was conservative
um so yes the left is unified and the
right is not
you know the paul ryan former speaker of
the house
who seems like a perfectly amiable
fellow is he's very much an economics
focused conservative and he really
doesn't seem to care very much about
cultural issues and he just gave a
speech the other day and he said you
know we got to stop talking about
how they're trying to trans the kids and
we got to stop talking about these
cultural things
which are just distractions we've got to
talk about the only important
conservative issue
namely cutting taxes a little bit more
once again and i thought you know
pal you you obviously don't know what
time it is here
but that we have to deal with that
problem the only thing that has united
the right
since the fall of the berlin wall has
been
cutting taxes okay we can't agree on
anything else
and so if you if you can't agree on
anything else then you're absolutely
right
you're not going to be able to enforce a
set of standards so
i'm hoping now i think there is some
hope
you're seeing on the right the the
ascendancy
of much more traditional serious
conservatives i'm thinking of guys like
so rob amari at the new york post who
just wrote the unbroken threads for a
very good book on this topic
guys like adrian vermeuel harvard law
professor really good on that topic
joram hazoni the the writer of virtue of
nationalism israeli philosophy is really
good patrick deneen why liberalism
failed i mean
this actually has really been emerging
this call for a substantive
conservative vision and so i hope that
we can get it but
are we there now absolutely thank you
very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace
you